a bipartisan group of senators did you
catch that part bipartisan group of
senators met in washington yesterday to
discuss possible gun safety legislation
any new federal law would be a major
breakthrough from columbine to sandy
hook to parkland we already know these
stories the conversation remains the
same something everybody says must be
done in the wake of these terrible
tragedies but congress has yet to find
common ground and there have been no
major changes to gun ownership laws in
this country doug high is a former
communications director for the
republican national committee he served
as deputy chief of staff for former
house majority leader eric cantor we're
also joined by we all know this man cbs
news chief political analyst john
dickerson we welcome you both to the
table
i think we can all agree republicans and
democrats agree they care about children
everybody gets choked up when they keep
talking about what has happened and
you've already yet we sit here again
do you think that things are different
this time doug well we've said they're
different time and time again and they
haven't been what tells me that this
might be slightly different this time if
not massively different is that we have
a group of senators as bipartisan that's
having conversations and one of the
problems in washington is regardless of
what the issue is but certainly when
it's something that's emotional is we
focus immediately on what the solution
is and it gets very hard in washington
to find the solution right now they're
looking at a solution or possible
solutions and that's where if i'm not
completely optimistic at least have some
cautious optimism that we're we're
talking about actual specifics and it's
not the loudest voices in the room that
are part of this what are the specifics
we should focus on john because i think
everybody just thinks assault rifles
have to go good we're talking about
background checks but assault rifles to
civilians who don't have formal training
why is that so hard that's not even on
the table and that table is not even in
the room so
and also by the way uh even if we're on
the table you'd have an immediate debate
about what an assault weapon is but
let's back up and what's actually being
discussed which is
some federal legislation that would
nudge states so again it's not federal
legislation that would do something but
that would that would get states in a
position to have red flag laws which are
essentially if you know somebody is
talking about
doing harm in school you can get a court
order to get their guns taken away from
them there are some states that already
have this indiana virginia others and so
there is there is some bipartisan
support around that but the key thing to
remember here you need 60 votes in the
senate to get anything done because the
filibuster means you need 60 votes so if
you're democrats and you can get all of
your 50 members aligned which is also
not certain you then need to find 10
republicans to get anything passed
anything that's going to get 10
republicans is not going to be anything
close to what you're talking about in
terms of assault weapons raising the age
for ownership of guns or and putting any
kind of measures in that people want
how is congress so far away from what
the polls say the american people are i
mean
the polls say 90 percent of americans
want some form of gun reform uh a pew
poll
says that 54 percent of americans want
stricter loss for gun sales
where's
where's the disconnect well there's no
member of congress there's no senator
that represents 90 of the voters they
represent their state and
vermont and montana and california north
carolina are all very different from
each other and you get in states like
california north carolina where they
have a lot of congressional districts
those districts are different from each
other and those members congress very
accurately reflects their voters if you
talk to a specific member of congress
they're representing their district
probably pretty well on issues like this
and the key point is representing their
district the nra spends a lot of money
supporting politicians but that money is
related to the feeling
of the member of the people in the
district so it's not just dollar bills
it's also the power of the voters in
those districts now the nra has been
very uh successful over the years in in
knitting together cultural identity and
gun ownership so that people feel it's
not just about guns anymore it's about
their entire way of life and that is a
relationship between the nra and voters
but it's not just about money that was
john's point that's not about lobbying
that's about voter contact it's who
republican members of congress hear from
when they go home it's who they hear
from on the campaign trail it's not
lobbying yes you can get these big poll
numbers but it really depends on the
specific states
and and so they're reacting to what
their constituents are saying that's
right if that sentiment of 90 doesn't
exist in at least 40 states to get you
past the threshold in the senate you're
not going to get any legitimacy what
about we saw a recent report that that
sentiment major minority leader excuse
me mitch mcconnell has said let's start
talking let's find some common ground
how important will that be because it
seems like nothing gets done with
republicans in the senate unless mitch
mcconnell's on board look he's he's the
leader for a reason and and he's the
first person that his members are going
to look to to follow i'm very encouraged
that john cornyn uh is part of this
process not just because he's from texas
and is seeing what's happening on the
ground but he's one of the real kind of
legislative leaders he's not what we
call a bomb thrower in the republican
caucus and my you know one of my
disappointments with donald trump of
which as a republican there were many is
i believe that donald trump could have
cut the deal on guns and even on
immigration that a president jeb bush or
president scott walker wouldn't have
been allowed he said he wanted to though
doug he said he wanted to yeah and if
you're looking you're the great deal
yeah if you're the great deal maker you
could have and should have been able to
do it and we'd be talking about a very
different political context not just
with what happened this week but what's
happening in houston this weekend so why
didn't he quickly
he's never moved his base anywhere he's
been so beholden to his base which we've
seen in these primaries is really about
a third of the party
do you think it's tone deaf for the nra
to be having their convention in texas
at this particular time i think it's
it's really bad timing um there's so
much planning that goes into these and
if you're if you're a mayor it's a
democratic mayor in houston you don't
want to lose those jobs that are coming
in for hotels and restaurants and all
these businesses that have been empty
they should try telling that to the 19
families you've passed this prologue the
speeches from the nra convention will be
uh very fiery and they will be
you're you are under attack they're
coming after your gun sales will go up
yeah that also happens we thank you both
it's good to see you in person john
dickerson great to have you at the table